The Girl, in the woods. Will be with you always.
she is your destiny.
I met a Witcher he saved my
life
now fetch him an ale before he goes to
Sodden,  hey Witcher, Witcher where are you going?
people linked by destiny will always find
each other who is Yennefer?
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my video for The Witcher
Netflix back half of the season the
ending I'll do a separate video about
season two so don't worry about that but
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos they've
already renewed the show for season two
they'll start shooting it next year but
obviously spoiler warning for everything
from Witcher episodes 5 through 8 pretty
short season but we'll do top 10 and
Easter eggs as we go along starting with
number 10 Geralt saves yennefer from the
jinn with his last wish I already talked
a little bit about this in my last video
so I'll go into slightly different
details during this but the whole idea
was that yennefer thought that she'd be
able to trap the jinn in her form and
use its power to heal herself so that
she'd eventually be able to have
children if she wanted to the reason why
yennefer can't have children those
because they surgically removed her
ability to have children burning her
ovaries on the pyre and using the
magical energy that that created to cast
the enchantments that made her look
beautiful but it's Geralt wish that
binds their fates together magically
intertwining their destinies so he saves
her with his last wish it's from a short
story in the books called
the last wish the magic of the wish just
causes their destinies to be intertwined
no one is really sure exactly what the
words he spoke were that caused their
destinies to be intertwined but however
he worded it however the jinn
interpreted that and then executed the
wish the magic of that is what causes
their destinies to be connected forever
that's why later in the season when they
run into each other on the dragon
adventure she says there's so few
witches in the world why do I keep
running it to you everywhere I go it's
the magic of the wish that keeps
bringing them back together no matter
how many times they're driven apart so
number 9 obviously Geralt saves the
golden dragons life and the baby dragon
egg this is from a short story in the
books called the bounds of Reason which
appears during the book sword of Destiny
but Geralt is hired by Bor ch3 jackdaws
to go kill a dragon come to find out
most of you probably figured this out
pretty early on with the way they were
seeding clues that Borch himself is the
dragon and a golden dragon at that it's
no accident that he hunts Geralt down to
try and find him to hire him for this
because Borch the dragon however you
want to think about him had heard the
stories that were being told about
Geralt the white wolf you could think
yeah skiier a little bit for the
- that's a bit of a funny callback to
him the bard singing all those songs and
crazy tales about Carrollton how good he
was everyone posts all your memes about
tossing coins - witchers respect us in
my history you notice that he's wearing
a dragon skin vest and when he's having
conversations with him around a campfire
specifically with Geralt he's really
just feeding Geralt questions so that
he'll give him answers and give him a
sense for what gerelds personality is
like does he really care about dragons
is he really a good person in through
Geralt explanation he explains that
dragons aren't evil they've been hunted
to extinction
so once of confirming a lot of the good
things that he heard about Geralt making
him feel a lot better about him helping
save him from the other hunters there's
also the line about golden dragons being
a rare mutation so this is meant to sort
of give them some sort of connection
because Geralt himself is the product of
a mutation just like the golden dragon
there were a couple big changes to the
way the book version of this story
played out but for the most part it all
ends up in the same place the dragon
then tells yennefer and Geralt that
their destinies will be forever
intertwined but yennefer will never be
able to have a child herself no matter
what she does and Geralt will eventually
lose yennefer but the thing about that
prophecy is a tricky thing if you've
watched Game of Thrones you know this
you should never interpret those things
quite so literally so like the magic of
the last wish will still bring them
together no matter how many times have
driven apart but like at the end of this
episode she's like you've lost me I'm
gone I'm out of here but the magic of
the wish will cause that to not stick
eventually they'll run into each other
probably during season two because they
don't meet each other before the end of
this season again but also even though
yennefer will never be able to
biologically have her own child she will
become the mother figure for another
child on the TV show number eight
garol tries to claim ciri through the
law of surprise we'll see how that goes
so ciri belongs to him by the law of
surprise which he called in the
flashback episode earlier during episode
4 when he saved dooney's life so you
have to imagine that more than 10 years
have gone by since that happened they
kind of fudged with the timeline a
little bit but Ciri is supposed to be
closer to 13 or 15 years old
the second time she meets Geralt in
present day but when Geralt comes back
it's before the fall of Cintra before
nilfgaard attacks Queen Calanthe as you
saw did another 180 and is determined
not to let Geralt have her there's an
important reason why she's kind of an
asshole about it but there is a reason
unless she tries to pass off the fake
this is totally my granddaughter ciri
why don't you take her right now but by
this time series mother pavetta has died
and Duney her father is also believed
to be dead they only briefly imply that
so I'm hoping they do another flashback
during season 2 to explain but if they
don't make it really clear why everyone
thinks that they're dead I'll include
that in a video but pavetta her mother
believed this ciri would only be safe
being raised by her mother and Cintra so
that's the main reason why ciri was
raised by Queen Calanthe in the main
reason why Calanthe doesn't want to
let Geralt tap her she's not crazy or
anything the TV show just isn't giving
you enough information so in order to
prevent Geralt from taking her in hoping
quote-unquote to avoid Destiny's wrath
chol anthe has Geralt thrown in the
dungeon but number seven we find out
that Geralt was in the dungeon while
nilfgaard was sacking Cintra this is all
happening on the orders of the usurper
king in nilfgaard it's not emperor Emhyr
it's a different character they never
really say what his name is in the books
he just referred to as the usurper but
he's also the person who's responsible
for placing the curse on Duney when
dune II was a little boy so hopefully
they'll get into that during season two
but because that's potentially spoilery
I won't talk about that here if you have
read the books please don't post
spoilers about what's going on with dune
II in the books we don't meet the
usurper this season on the show or
anything like that maybe we'll see him
during season two but there is a lot of
important stuff going on in the
background up in nilfgaard separate from
what's happening with Geralt and Ciri
down here number six though Yennefer
meets Vilgefortz, the other mage
from the Brotherhood of sorcerers and
one of the main antagonists from the
books at least in the future like I said
they're fudging the timeline a little
bit this is meant to be Vilgefortz
before he becomes one of the bigger
antagonists the way the actor is playing
him seems kind of ambiguous I think
that's actually in the character of most
of the other sorcerers that you meet at
the Brotherhood of sorcerers like Strega
Bor is kind of a terrible person but
he's not any more evil necessarily than
a lot of the other bad characters that
you meet during the course of the show
but the
point of the introduction here is a big
change to the book story because it's
all leading up to the Battle of sodden
hill in the fall of the Brotherhood of
sorcerers which I'll talk about in a
second all this episode 7 stuff is
really just a lot of table setting to
sort of give you background on these
characters and sort of introduced them
before they become bigger characters
during season two they give you a sense
for what Vilgefortz' personality is he is a
good mage but he spent a lot of time in
campaigns and Wars so he's very hungry
for battle they changed a lot of what's
going on with the story line around the
Battle of sodden hill and the fall of
the brotherhood of sorcerers so I don't
know if there's any secret shady stuff
going on in the background or if this is
just meant to be exactly the way you see
it but number five the fall of the
Brotherhood of sorcerers so the Battle
of sodden hill on the TV show seems like
they're combining a bunch of different
book plots together to streamline the
fall of the Brotherhood and the rise of
the lodge of sorceresses
which is like the next big organization
of mages that come together in the ashes
of the Brotherhood they make this big
deal about freeing gila trying to lure
them to nilfgaard under the auspices
that they'll be able to practice magic
freely of any rules or restrictions
forbidden magic all the fring gila stuff
though is mostly a big change to the
books the end result for their
organization is still the same they
suffer heavy losses and then even later
campaigns from Emperor Emhyr
effectively in their Brotherhood's power
but number four the actual Battle of
sodden hill the big war that they fight
as stated this is the stand of the
Brotherhood makes against nilfgaard
mostly because they feel like nilfgaard
is getting too powerful not because they
care about all these neighboring
kingdoms it's not a genuine source of
compassion or anything like that they
just feel like if nilfgaard unifies the
continent they'll start placing more
rules and restrictions on the
Brotherhood and they don't want anybody
telling them what to do we see that
nilfgaard the rogue mages freeing gila
fight really dirty causing heavy
casualties because what's happening with
Geralt and Cirie is right next to this I
think they'll probably dressed it's at
the beginning of season two because
Geralt knows that yennefer is fighting
at the Battle of sodden Hill so he tries
to go find her there but there's all
these unmarked graves so he believes
that she's so alive but doesn't confirm
that till a little bit later
number three friend Gil is forbidden
magic it's not so much that they're
using super dark magic it's more that
they're ignoring a lot of the safety
protocols that the Brotherhood of
sorcerers adhere by to protect
themselves and preserve their own lives
all magic comes with a cost
the forbidden aspect of this is that
friend Gila is having these random rogue
mages working for nilfgaard completely
consumed their life force to produce
extra powerful magics Yennefer's Power
Move to burn through the army with that
giant area of effect attack isn't
forbidden either it's more about her
fully committing herself to the cause
because previously she really just
didn't care about what they were doing
she didn't care about the other
neighboring kingdoms any of the Kings
any of the people in them she didn't
want have anything to do with the real
world part of the reason why she seems
so much more naturally powerful than the
other mages as they implied earlier in
the season is because she's half elven
and elves have a much deeper connection
to magic she's not as naturally powerful
as someone like Ciri who has the elder
blood but yennefer has been training as
a witch for decades and decades and Ciri
has no idea how her powers work number
two this is actually a big one may
not have been totally clear but Geralt
meets his mother Vicente
he has all these hallucinations and
flashbacks so if it wasn't clear what's
happening here this is him actually
meeting his mother and it's not just a
hallucination she actually does come to
help him here in this moment and if it
wasn't clear the reason why she looks so
young is because she was a sorceress
that's why during the flashbacks when
he's a little boy they never show you
what her face looks like just to make
you wonder oh wait a minute she's a
sorceress just like yennefer and the
other ones so she lives way longer than
everyone else she left Geralt and Cara
morhen as a child with The Witcher
School of the wolf but the best
explanation that I could give you is
that she did care for him but she felt
like she couldn't care for him like a
real mother could and the best chance
for him for a good upbringing would be
to give him to the school the wolf but
the really tricky thing like I said
nobody on the show is truly evil or
truly good it's all shades of gray
she knew that most children given to the
school of the wolf died during the trial
of grasses so she totally understood
that there was a really high probability
that he could die
they don't really address Gerald's
father during these flashbacks but his
father is most likely the warrior
Corinne who appears during this side
book outside of the main novels maybe
we'll see him in a flashback in a future
season but I'm not really expecting it
they don't spend a lot of time devoted
to his character in the main novel
series he just
rinsed every once in a while
occasionally but number one Geralt in
ciri finally meet each other in the
woods near sodden hill and ciri
unleashes her elder blood full powers
without realising what's going on and
it's all about their destinies being
intertwined the same way that Geralt
destiny with yennefer is being
intertwined that's also why at the
beginning of this episode you see the
three sigils on the title screen formed
together around each other because all
three of their destinies are now
intertwined so they'll probably spend
most of the early part of season 2
catching up on where they've been and
what they're going to do next while all
this nilfgaard and usurper stuff going
on in the north sorts itself out because
that is still a very big deal going on
in the background there's all this stuff
that's coming up with Vilgefortz'
character Emperor Emhyr, I don't know how
much they're fudging the timeline so the
minute we get some clues about that I
will include it in videos the TV show
has changed a little bit about the way
series powers work but you kind of get a
sense for what may have happened you
just meant to imagine it in your head
how she just Visser ated all these other
people without completely understanding
how she used her abilities the way the
games treat her abilities are a little
bit different so I'll probably do a
video at some point just explaining how
that all works because you could spend
all day talking about how crazy powerful
she is she's like God - you're powerful
compared to all the other people on the
show
but let me know in the comments what was
your favorite moment from the season and
what are you hoping that they do during
season 2 I will do a season 2 video
sometime in the next couple of days
because they won't start shooting for a
little while but we have a pretty good
idea for what story they're going to
adapt while you wait for everything
click here for my brand new Star Wars
baby Yoda and Mandalorian video and
click here for all my other Witcher Netflix
episode videos thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight!